[Music]
sterling is in raleigh north carolina hi
sterling welcome to the ramsey show
hey thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
hey so i am 17 um i have a one thousand
dollar car uh i have five thousand
dollars in a roth ira and i'm putting
500 in a month right now
um i make about 1500 a month and i'm
still doing full-time high school
uh i've got free college and i've been
through financial peace university and
i'm trying to figure out what i need to
do with my money and if i need to open
an index fund or how i should be setting
aside money for a house
i think you should run for president
oh my gosh young man you're on you're on
fire what are you doing to make all this
money
uh so i started out as a painter when i
was 15. my dad helped me get the job and
then right now i'm working as a hvac
cleaner so i help a guy clean air ducts
and
dryer vents yeah
nice my husband did that through college
sterling yeah
yeah yeah that's hard work it's nasty
work too but you're not afraid of hard
work get get her done man i'm proud of
you very well done so uh you're heading
off to school is that is that the plan
what's the plan when you graduate
yes sir so i'm a junior right now i'm
playing on dual enrolling some this next
year um and hopefully i'll get some
college hours in and then once i
graduate high school i'm planning on
hopefully i'm thinking about majoring in
business and then maybe going to trade
school at some point after
i
that
that's my plan so far i think you got a
great plan very cool very cool so your
question is what to do with all this
money
yes sir should i be saving it up for a
house should i be putting this in an
index fund because i'm already maxing
out my roth ira how's college paid for
uh so my dad actually works at a college
right now so i get a free tuition and
he's got like half the books i need okay
all right i would i would not try to get
too fancy i'm just gonna park it as an
insurance policy to make sure that if
something goes sideways on the free part
of the college you can still finish
um and yes so worst case scenario is you
have i don't know 30 or 40 or 50 000
when you graduate oh darn and then you
just have to figure out buying a house
at that point but if you've got that in
a good mutual fund just do something
like an index fund i think that'd be
just fine but the big deal here is
sometimes uh
some of our our our plans get derailed
and i i always want it's more important
for you as especially sharp and as much
of an ambition and much of a go-getter
as you are
to complete school and to complete it
debt-free
that is more valuable than any amount of
money you will ever make on a mutual
fund in terms of the actual math
in other words you will be more valuable
by
many times more than this money will
make in a mutual fund so the investment
is my secondary concern my primary
concern is you and making sure that if
if something blew up over there with
your dad or whatever then you can still
finish school and if you and if it
doesn't if the plan goes exactly as you
got it laid out you're still going to
have a pile of money for you know your
first to get into your first job in your
first house and that kind of thing yeah
because i'd love the
obviously the motivation of investing in
all that sterling you're you're doing it
right the earlier the better but also
kind of with the caveat that between 17
and 22 years old there's a lot of
transition there's a lot of change you
have no clue kind of what life is going
to bring you and so
you're not going to not become wealthy
if you start really kind of hardcore
investing at 22 versus 17 if that makes
sense so having that cash available like
you're saying dave i think is so smart
because again whether you go to college
and then you're like okay i want to move
to a different state i'm going to need
cash to be able to move
who knows maybe you meet a girl and
you're like i want to propose and you're
going to get a ring like there's just so
much transition that can happen
in that time and so giving yourself the
ability to have margin with cash to be
able to kind of move and go at the pace
you want
is worth it and then once you kind of
settle down after college and figure out
where you're going to live your big your
first job and all of that
then go hardcore into the investing
because that's where you're going to be
which is freaking amazing that you're
going to be on baby steps four five and
six i'm not sure who parents who
sterling's dad and mom are but i think
they are they get the award okay
yes
but i wanted to ask him too
there is something though that there is
something in certain people that they
just have this drive and i see that in
my kids like you have kind of that you
know you have kids that they just have
this natural
motivation their natural wiring is they
love making anybody naturally cleansed
air ducts
to go and work though no that works
i don't think his parents are making him
do that is what i'm saying like there's
something in sterling in in and in
people and it's like they just have that
drive so i'm just applauding him he's
doing an amazing thing
i'm not i'm not taking anything away
from you and your parents for sure have
done an incredible job teaching you and
showing you so it is um it's all of it
which is awesome great job
actually have fun too sterling have fun
have fun
you're 17. you're good you're gonna be
good have fun